Бути "в належному місці, в належний час
і з належним обладнанням".
Це головна мета створення країнами НАТО двох нових командних центрів.
Перш за все - щоб відповісти на анексію Криму
Росією та розв’язання бойових дій на Донбасі.
Міністри оборони країн-членів Альянсу, які зібралися на зустріч у Брюсселі,
не приховують, що нові безпекові загрози походять, передусім з Росії.
Ми будемо працювати задля того, щоб упевнитись: НАТО має структури
і здатність боротися з дедалі зростаючими загрозами,
з якими зіткнулася Європа, особливо з боку Росії.
Ми повинні переконатись, що Європа готова до викликів.
Активність російський підводних човнів нині найвища з часів "холодної війни".
У НАТО припускають, що Росія може навмисно пошкодити підводні кабелі,
які забезпечують зв'язок між Європою, США і Канадою.
За даними командування підводних сил НАТО, ніколи досі Росія
не появляла такої зацікавленості до підводної інфраструктури Альянсу.
Тож новий командний центр НАТО має захисти морські комунікації в Атлантиці
і буде розміщений, швидше за все, на території Сполучених Штатів.
Другий командний центр відповідатиме за логістику військ,
перш за все, за те, щоб в разі кризової ситуації країна-член НАТО
швидко отримала підтримку, зокрема й техніку та озброєння.
Німеччина пропонує розмістити цей командний центр на своїй території,
зважаючи на географічні переваги та досвід у сфері логістики та підтримки військ.
Агресивна політика Росії, зокрема щодо України поклала край тенденції,
яка панувала в НАТО близько чверть століття.
Після розвалу Радянського Союзу інфраструктуру в Європі будували
для цивільного використання, часто не враховуючи військові потреби.
Наприклад, мости, вокзали - багато з них зовсім не розраховані на танки.
Крім того, існує велика бюрократія. Перевезти техніку через кордон - це дуже довго.
Лише розгляд заявки триває 45 днів.
І сам для того, щоб полегшити і пришвидшити перекидання військ як з Америки до Європи,
так і з Західної Європи, наприклад, до країн Балтії чи Польщі, і потрібні ці два нових управління.
Важливо, що над проблемою військової мобільності працює не лише НАТО, але і ЄС.
Під час "холодної війни" було 33 центри командування НАТО.
Потім їх скоротили до 7.
Так само зменшили й особовий склад - з 22 тисяч до менш ніж 7 тисяч.
Нині ж через агресивну політику Росії, тероризм та кіберзагрози
оборонні бюджети країн НАТО зростають, військова техніка модернізується.
Цього року ми очікуємо, що вісім країн-союзників досягнуть мети
- довести витрати на оборону до двох відсотків ВВП.
А до 2024 року, сподіваємось, вже принаймні 15 союзників
витрачатимуть на оборону стільки ж або більше.
Початок обнадійливий, але ми повинні акивніше працювати.
Протягом найближчих місяців у НАТО розподілятимуть
обов’язки та розроблятимуть детальний план функціонування штабів.
Й остаточне рішення, передусім щодо розташування нових структур
та кількості персоналу, ухвалять у червні перед самітом Альянсу.